[Musique]
yoran accès à happy après aulas saviez
vous qu'il existe dans le monde plus de
4000 langue écrite et parlée énorme sur
ses quatre mille langues d'ici 2100 donc
d'ici 80 ans 90% d'entre elles
disparaîtront
ça aussi c'est énorme pour ne pas dire
alarmant la problématique des langues
autochtones et de leur disparition est
tellement importante que l'onu a décrété
et décidé que l'année 2019 serait
l'année de la protection des langues
autochtones
mon histoire avec la langue tahitienne
notamment qui est une de ces langues
autochtones qui risque de disparaître et
éventuellement évidemment pardon
parental mon père est né à ruiner ma
maman à trith y est les deux à louis est
la même les origines danoises
je sais ça ne se voit pas la blanchir de
la peau danoise a complètement été avalé
par me gêne maori et pourtant c'est vrai
donc j'ai des origines haïtiennes et
danoise
je n'ai jamais été lésés culturellement
parlant
mon père a été pendant des décennies
professeur de gym et n'est donc de
chants traditionnels aux conservateurs
l'artistique
j'ai fait avec lui voilà même dit
tournée j'ai grandi dans ce bain
culturel et a fortiori la culture m'a
toujours intéressé donc la langue aussi
comme beaucoup de polynésiens de jeunes
polynésiens aujourd'hui je comprends
très bien - rio mais je ne la plastique
pas et je ne la parlent pas et c'est
vraiment une grosse problématique pour
moi parce que au final même si j'ai béni
dans ce bain culturel je me suis
toujours dit c'est bizarre en fait je
n'arrive pas à débloquer je n'arrive pas
à parler serez au qui en plus une langue
magnifique et il ya dix ans je venais
donc d'un master en métropole j'ai fait
de la sociologie de la communication
je reviens avec
ma soeur en poche et je me dis ok je
verrai après le retard c'est vraiment
bien les choses c'est ici à la maison la
culture avec maxime enter que j'ai repli
les cours de route et qui dans une des
salles qui est pas loin j'ai voulu aller
plus loin en faisant du hall héros de
l'art oratoire avec l'excellent john may
au conservatoire artistique de polynésie
française et j'ai voulu encore aller
plus loin en faisant donc un certificat
universitaire à l'université police de
politique française avec edith maraya
notamment tous les toits m'ont apporté
une richesse linguistique extraordinaire
et surtout humaine et je reviendrai
dessus parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important pour moi
cette l'échelle humaine qui nous
caractérise beaucoup ici en polynésie et
malgré toutes ces expériences malgré
tous ses coups que j'ai pu faire
et bien finalement j'arrive et quand
même pas à débloquer ça et je me suis
dit non mais c'est quand même bizarre
chapuis je suis pas une cinquantaine de
cours tu comprends très bien mais tu
n'arrives pas à parler ton réau
et là je me suis dit ok souvent par de
la honte
d'ailleurs moi je vais pas je vais
laisser steve chaillou tout à l'heure
aborder ce sujet avec vous puisque c'est
sa santé mais au delà de la honte
au final quels sont les facteurs les
caisses qui fait qu' on n'arrive pas à
débloquer ce cette honte ou en tout cas
ce passage-là cette barrière de du par
les ailes et haute et y est donc il ya
dix ans faut que je me mette comme ça
j'avais vingt kilos en plus il ya trois
ans pardon pas 10 ans et j'étais
enceinte en fait et c'est vraiment à ce
moment là que le déclic est arrivé donc
j'attendais ma fille faye mano qui va
bientôt avoir de 3 ans et comme beaucoup
de futurs parents je me suis toujours
posé la question de hockey comme qu'est
ce que tu vas t'on se mettre là ta fille
en passant de langue maternelle
comment est ce que tu vas faire
finalement pour l'échangé avec elle si
au final en fait tu n'arrives pas à
parler tant au léo et c'est quelque
chose de vraiment fondamental en fait et
donc il ya trois ans je me suis dit ok
non il faut vraiment que tu fasses
quelque chose tu vas voir ta petite
fille il faut que tu arrives à lui
parler henriot et je me suis souvenu
d'une histoire que mon oncle m'a raconté
il ya une cinquantaine d'années
aujourd'hui et lui en fait il n'a réussi
à parler
rio que à 18 ans qu'est ce qui s'est
passé à 18 ans en fait on l'a amené
faire le passé des vacances dans une
famille aux tuamotu tant qu'un des
archipels polynésiens et à la bahia
personnes qui parlent français et là
c'est là où en fait c'est là où l'humain
est extraordinaire parce qu'au final ils
n'arrivaient pas à parler son réseau
mais il est passé en mode survie
c'est à dire que ben il fallait bien
manger quoi et donc du coup ben comme il
fallait parler il
ça a débloqué d'un coup il était en fait
en immersion et c'est là en fait que je
me suis dit au final aujourd'hui on
appelant tous à vouloir parler donc
l'anglais en faisant des séjours
linguistiques en nouvelle-zélande aux
états unis en devenant un plan de
l'espagnol au chili pourquoi est ce
qu'on ferait pas ça ici
pourquoi est ce qu'on ferait pas des
séjours d'immersion linguistique dans
nos familles tahitienne et c'est vrai à
chaque fois que j'en parle et jocelyne
bah oui alors oui la l'eau et donc je me
suis dit ok et ben ali on y va et en
fait non parce que c'est plus compliqué
qu'on eut conclu qu on le pense
les séjours linguistiques moi c'est
quelque chose vers lesquels j'irai plus
tard mais pour ce qui est de fin il
fallait trouver quelque chose de
prototype à bhl donc de faire au moins
des immersions en effet ici aujourd'hui
voilà on ne vous propose pas de faire
une visite au musée de faire du café une
expérience culturelle immersive en reo
tahiti à quel moment est ce que vous
allez vous dire bah oui en fait c'est
sympa c'est bien de la plante en fait
d'apprendre tout ce qu'on fait en france
est aujourd'hui de le faire dans nos
longs pourquoi pas et en fait de tous
ces cheminements du fait que j'étais
enceinte les hormones patati patata
là je me suis dit ok je vais me lancer
et je vais faire ça et c'est là où j'ai
voulu innover
je me suis dit ok ben voilà l'innovation
pour moi d'abord elle est humaine vous
souvenez j'ai dit que c'était très
important
pourquoi humaine parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui au fenway je suis pas la
seule heureusement on y plein en fait il
ya énormément de gens d'associations qui
font revivre qui font en sorte que cette
langue soit vie
hantée vibrante des expériences des
cours de danse de chant en fait il ya
beaucoup d'initiatives comme ça qu'ils
existent mais en fait j'ai voulu aller
un peu plus loin et donc je me suis
entouré humainement de gens j'ai proposé
à ces gens là un peu comme à la veille
alain vient monde sur mon bateau vient
avec moi dans ce va à la et vient
pagayer avec moi c'est du sport pour le
reo tahiti et ça fonctionne innovation
aussi digital parce que souvent quand on
parle d'innovation on pense au digital
en fait la transmission de la langue
c'est vraiment une transmission qui se
faisait qui se fait encore un petit peu
via nos grands parents nos parents nos
emplois nos tentes
mais si aujourd'hui ils sont de moins en
moins s'ils ne peuvent pas s'ils ne
veulent pas parce que malheureusement
c'est aussi le cas comment faire au
final pour que ce savoir là on puisse le
mettre et le transmettre dans deux
usages numériques dans un ordinateur
dans un téléphone portable
et là c'est vraiment une boîte de
pandore qu'on ouvre c'est à dire que moi
j'ai été appelé pour développer un
assistant vocal on est de tahiti
quand je dis à plessé des gens de
l'extérieur j'ai été sollicité pour
faire des traductions de comic books
notamment donc des bandes dessinées qui
sont mis en ligne et en fait il ya
énormément d'exemples de plateformes de
e learning qui peuvent se créer et on
peut vraiment construire quelque chose
utiliser l'innovation et tout ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui pour pouvoir rendre
vivante vibrante pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que voilà l'heureux haute et y
sent le plus diffusé et c'est vraiment
sur ça qu'il faut qu'on insiste aussi
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que utiliser
tous les réseaux en fait on est tous
pareils ça dure que l'on a nos usages
numériques
la vidéo à la demande dont ni sur les
réseaux sociaux utilisent tous des
applications et pourquoi pas justement
utiliser tout ça pour pouvoir faveur en
tout cas du reo tahiti pour qu'elle
puisse être diffusé et du coup comment
faire en fait comment transformer
l'essai
bah déjà en essayant déjà en proposant
des emails sans faire en sorte que
justement tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
en français on le fasse enlever
authority vous savez moi je suis
époustouflée parce que depuis quelques
mois depuis que je me suis vraiment
lancé avec d'autres dans cette quête de
deux pas de la survivance parce que leur
est honni pas mort mais dans cette quête
de la diffusion du lot teddy je suis
époustouflée aussi par le nombre de
personnes extérieures qui me sollicitent
ils sont japonais viennent d'amérique
latine sont de france même du pacifique
et moi en fait je me suis toujours dit
ok c'est très bien ça veut dire que
notre langue intéresse d'autres
personnes mais comment faire qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire justement pour que ça
soit la même chose ici et moi qui ai
fait des études de sociologie et des
communications je me suis dit ok en fait
c'est du marketing limites il faut la
vendre soi que cette langue
la ronde à la mode désirable parce que
c'est ce que ça c'est ce qui marche
ailleurs et pour la rendre ça y est
désirable il faut voilà proposés et dire
aux gens ben oui vient il ya des coups
il ya des espaces qui existent
aujourd'hui il faut en créer d'autres
et davantage et moi je vois de plus en
plus qu'il ya des espaces qui se créé
justement pour faire des immersions pour
des adultes et des enfants
il faut aussi créer une méthodologie ou
en tout cas un apprentissage qui puisse
être aussi bien pour les enfants que
pour les adultes aussi bien pour les
polynésiens que pour les étrangers parce
que ces gens là aussi envie naples ont
envie d'aller plus loin dans cet
apprentissage est dans cet intérêt pour
la culture
moi j'aimerais terminer juste en vous
demandant de fermer les yeux je vous
vois donc il faut vraiment fermer les
yeux
j
[Musique]
nous allons coller le carreau
colling pour le catalan était très connu
ce que vous venez d'entendre fait c'est
une des langues aborigènes qui existe
encore aujourd'hui qui est utilisé
notamment dans une application en
australie pour la méditation et cette
application est utilisé partout dans les
écoles au travail est quotidiennement
pour vous si vous voulez donc faire de
la méditation
j'adore cet exemple en fait parce que
c'est un des exemples parmi des
centaines qui existent aujourd'hui pour
la survivance et la prise la
préservation des langues
c'est à dire que cette solution est à la
fois innovantes digitales
elle porte un message fort c'est que
même si nos langues autochtones sont de
moins en moins parler ce n'est pas pour
ça qu'il ne faut plus les utiliser que
ces langues autochtones aujourd'hui
peuvent être même utilisé dans la
médecine contemporaine et peuvent
justement et des ah oui à grandir à sa
mieux en tout cas c'est une application
pour le bien-être mental et donc pour
moi c'était vraiment important de
participer tedx aujourd'hui parce que
moi je crois vraiment qu'il faut
partager ses idées
je pense qu'une langue qui disparaît
effectivement c'est une c'est un peuple
qui meurt avec des valeurs par derrière
aussi et moi mon message en fait je
terminerais juste sur le fait que si
vous aussi vous avez envie d'embarquer
dans ce beau va'a n'hésitez surtout pas
essayer voilà petit à petit le rêve que
moi je fais souvent voilà d'entendre le
plus leurs hôtes et tiges le fait
actuellement avec ma fille juste
quelques mots même avec eux quand vous
allez chercher votre pain justin y aura
un mort deux jours et pour moi c'est
vraiment important parce que il faut
qu'on puisse se fédérer pour que
justement le reo tahiti ne fasse pas
partie des 90 % des langues qui risque
de disparaître d'ici quatre ans avant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]